[Music]  madison thank you in other news tonight  metro police are investigating after a  body was found near a construction site  in summerlin officers say they've  received the call around 7 this morning  near alta and crossbridge drive we're  told construction workers discovered the  body and notified police  we do have a deceased male who has yet  to be identified who is down in the  desert with apparent trauma to their  head  we have no specific cause of death at  this time we're still waiting the  coroner's office to further the  investigation  as stated this is currently just deemed  a suspicious death investigation  the area is a popular hiking location  with a lot of new home developments  going up nearby there is no suspect  information at this time if you know  anything you're asked to call crime stop